[Music]
and [ __ ] up parenting news home
submitted by Monica YouTube star daddy
oh five lost custody of two of his
children featured in a viral prank video
video what is daddy oh five very huge
immediate community well I obviously
don't know [ __ ] I don't know what's
going on oh well I will show you in No
am I going to feel a certain type of way
about this you are hey I'm so excited I
love to you may or you may not like it
Michael and Heather Michael is 34 years
old Heather's 33 years old you guys know
they look way older than that by the way
you do okay so I'm so curious I don't
know anything okay yeah so this is the
Martin family right so they're they have
a YouTube channel where which is called
w5 and it's because Michael has five
children he has three children with
Heather and two children with a previous
relationship and her name is rose okay
so the kids are Jake who's 14 Ryan who's
12 Alex who's 9 Cody who's also 9 and
Emma who's 11 now the last two kids I
mentioned our roses kids so they're all
from Baltimore Maryland and this whole
thing blew up because they have been
posting a lot of videos of them pranking
their kids and like they're just showing
a lot of what seems to be abuse like
physical and emotional and mental abuse
and so I'm going to show you guys
snippets of this particular prank video
that went viral and what it is it's so
Heather the mom is she buys this fake
pink and she sprays all over the carpet
to prank Cody and so it seems like
Cody's like the main kid that they tend
to pick on a lot which is really sad
like used to be him like you look
emotionally distressed but according to
the parents he was acting who knows it
was true so in this particular video
about the ink she spreads all over the
carpet first yelling and I'm cussing at
him like it's just soda Serena
and then like a kid is just like sobbing
things they doing to do it and it's
freaking out if he's acting he deserves
an Oscar because that's really
supporting everyone I was like laughing
in my head
clearly I don't know about the situation
now I'm not laughing I'm going to show
you guys snippets of that first viral
video she's burning through my eyes with
all this buzz that's what I said
what the hell's here to stand on her
face every morning just stop all the
water and dinner
[Applause]
[Music]
laughing you pretended by stander yeah
he's got oh it's just ah that's crazy
it's crazy that they do that for
entertainment and they also share that
it looks like how they yell at Marines
at boot camp whether like either yelling
at a show ideas are just stupid they're
like oh what do i do I control all this
[ __ ] I think like to me the treatment
and the yelling isn't the part that
bothers me
because that's how I grew up every day
so my parents don't have me like crazy
like that every single day but the part
that bothers me is that that was real
you know I did something to trigger some
sort of reaction for my parents I
probably [ __ ] up did something I
wasn't supposed to do they're doing that
for fun to prank the kid at
entertainment I thought so this is less
than money yeah that's the point it's
not okay you ain't really seen people
you could tell straight up and this is
what I kind of don't like about a lot of
like recent youtubers is that they
thrive off of other people's attention
yeah I mean and that's the only way they
can exist so you can tell these two
[ __ ] we're losers growing up their
whole [ __ ] life I'm gonna [ __ ] what
you people say out there I already know
for a fact
losers their whole [ __ ] life and for
the first time in their life they
finally getting attention from people
that are laughing maybe with them
whereas I don't really [ __ ] know but
they're feeding off that [ __ ] and this
is the type of [ __ ] that I [ __ ] hate
being most and the weird thing is is
like you could actually tell that these
people are using their kids as tools and
you're my [ __ ] like you know cash cow
like that whole you know what a jonbenét
Ramsey tend to think that derringer
they're saying I'm he makes money off of
these videos and the mom is an
accountant so dad doesn't really have
like a nine-to-five just how is she 33
years old that is [ __ ] she is
obviously close to like 45 you know I
couldn't find her age and a lot of these
articles are reporting them but I lift
up on like famous birthdays or something
and that's the age that they gave me I
don't even know if that's my god she
looks like she's gonna blow drying her
face the whole time Franco did an
excellent end of video to expose like
this channel and to bring attention to
it because he was really deeply
disturbed by what he watched and so like
his team did a lot of research and they
comb through like all their videos that
they had and and he actually did
multiple videos about this but because
of him exposing this a lot of fans
started downloading all of their videos
because as of now they deleted all of
their videos on their channel there you
only have one video up and that's like
their apology they deleted all the
videos after Channel well actually they
private it it oh yeah a private but um
so yeah they just can't be downloaded
anymore but fans were able to get them
downloaded before a date went private
and so a lot of fans started making
these like compilation videos of all the
abuse I'm going to show you one of those
videos and it's mainly Kodi that gets he
would do this one and his sister two
younger sister Emma which are both the
kids are from a different mother
Paul's either not even their biological
mother Matt is pasta [ __ ] sweet with
you I think is he's so emotional to he
gives like a really genuine you know I
was breaking like this but according to
them he needs to win like he's going to
be an actor in the future because he's
just amazing and I think oh yeah that's
um we're an amazing acting he goes like
I [ __ ] hate it I hate it I be crazy
absolutely your scene thank you mother
never walk away that's what they need a
big issue BTS for their channel and show
him go scene boom it's completely done
and it's cool
everyone laugh and smile and hug and
then perfect then you don't even have to
take down any instead of private videos
just got to make more videos to show you
how to scene
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh Oh No get out of the chair
hmm
now take your the other Snickers okay
back with a little it's just right so
you all made me go all through all this
service oh and the really good actor
Oscar did he needs an Oscar
the writing was so good - the script so
if it's not seem very real
yeah that kid's gonna grow [ __ ] up and
I hope I hope you couldn't like really
somebody can do a really good job of
helping like like process all the [ __ ]
that's going to happen because that like
[ __ ] that happened to the kid Allegiant
all the way - you're an adult I was a
biological mom Rose she lives in North
Carolina I'll get into that in a little
bit
um so yeah Cody siblings constantly
abused them and it's creepy like you
they like film there's a sad base it's
like dead honey ha ha or maybe they're
just kids but yeah and then so so you
know they accused him of bad behavior
and then like punished him for it and
then they also smashes a toy a great
they're just constantly like poking at
him to get more and more upset and you
guys saw in that compilation video of
like Michael his father actually pushed
him into a bookshelf like face-first and
his reason for that was because oh he
came running up to me and like it was
just my reflex to push on so a mug but
it's like I need to grab them into the
are you crazy
I wish the lies were better like yeah
it's pretty bad but then waiting so I
get to be the apology video follow these
pants [ __ ] that channel a shoulder
busting just working my bullet animation
this is a video Emma getting slapped in
the face it's because the dad said
alright we're going to do his water
bottle flip challenge and whoever
doesn't get it gets left to the face
until I sign he was like you not
supposed to hit girls Basu dishes sure
so it doesn't count
guys like what crazy so then going into
the biological mother so Rose says that
she has now obtained emergency custody
of her two children she said that when
she initially saw the videos in the
channel it should just cried as she had
an anxiety attack she lives in North
Carolina but she says that she did have
custody of them up until 2014 where she
alleges that the children were taken
from her illegally and unfairly and that
the Martins had forged paperwork from
her granting them permanent
my custody and that they also used
intimidation tactics in the custody
battle so I'm not sure of like all the
details there but that's from the mom
that's what the momma same situation all
[ __ ] up
and the momento said nice person yeah I
hope so too here the photo over there
she look like don't tell me she's 33 200
she looks like um like maybe the Wendy's
girls out there entire man or something
I would pay to see Rose [ __ ] up the
other mom yeah in a sanction fight [ __ ]
yeah she did an interview she was like
I'm so glad I wasn't in the same room as
them I was like as they were losing my
children I'm actually upset that she's
not in the room they put them in a room
somebody Zubaydah happen don king daeso
these types of motions okay put them in
a room out of here so Rosa saying that
she told the Maryland authorities about
the channel back in October
but then the Maryland authorities are
saying that they didn't even know about
the videos until this went into the
public's eye also better china fishy and
then the detectives in North Carolina
were able to confirm that yes there was
filed a police report saying that you
know there was these videos back in
October 17th and that you know the
Maryland a CPS didn't do anything the
government for you dude they always said
we didn't get it we didn't get it always
like that do you even like a clip where
like um I don't know if Erica this with
the philip defranco but the kids are
like so [ __ ] up that they're like yeah
like it's just a prank it's not like
you're abusive or anything like what
it's so weird
after this initial viral video they
uploaded another video reacting to all
the hate and that that's the video that
Jill's talking about where the kids is
like well if you don't be those like
other parents like they have low
standards like preparing what so school
yeah and so they were also saying that
people who oppose that video or just
haters and that by criticizing their
videos all their that the people hating
on the video are hurting the kids that's
what the parents are saying like you're
upsetting our head of art please it's
all [ __ ]
was good so then and they're also saying
that the kid prank the parents back just
videos videos I want to see the kids
[ __ ] the parents up by heating up the
iron and putting on a dad's face
honestly videos like that can't do the
slap challenge with the mom and dad how
about the moment yeah well let's do that
it's a prank bro yeah who's this bro
this polka negro this is a tag line
every time they [ __ ] with it like she
[ __ ] with the kids
she's a prank bro I want to see a mouse
trap on the dad's dick so in that first
video they were already saying like yeah
we're in family counseling but they kind
of look like whatever
um and then well I thought they had
there's something wrong so why that
family counseling yeah exactly yeah so
then the second video this was this is
um
after the video that field to Franco
posted about them this is after the fact
they posted a video and here's a
screenshot of what they look like in
that video
oh god and so there were others they
were apologizing but more for the fact
that this got way out of hand and they
we please look like pretty much all of
the blame on philip defranco saying it's
his fault he ruined our family war was
because of him my wife was almost ran
off the road ever like he calls all of
this in our family they're dumb they're
losers and they're dumb that dude looks
like Eminem stepdad from 8 mile yeah but
then I saw that investment just wrinkle
uploaded video in response like you guys
do some mental Olympics to get like to
make that make sense in your head so
yeah so that happened and then there was
a third video which is an actual apology
video so it seems that they hired a
crisis management firms like a PR firm
to help them with this video and a video
this it's been viewed almost four
million times if you monetize on their
channels but Michael was saying like it
was my decision to demolish I know
whybut all of our videos the YouTube was
like now we've been monetize it a little
can we just talk why are you that's
what's tough about William DeFranco like
he was members I mean that's a cellphone
Philip DeFranco is that like in the
beginning of his video he just said that
he's going to monetize everything to
these life I'm not like this is news but
like it's hitting me so personally that
I don't want you guys to think that I'm
jumping on this chain yet we got to yeah
I guess good I had one yeah my obvious
kid or kids related apartment he was
just like I'm not doing it for fame or
two he's like this just really hit home
for me so I'm - monetizing these next
videos or whatever I'm like that you
don't well there's a fragrant killer
yeah that's the street names I did like
it she's messing up so much lately funny
yeah but um so in conclusion they have
reported that tell Protective Services
and the County Sheriff's Office are
investigating and they haven't charged
them with anything but just hopefully
this these kids begin at the help that
they need to fully process everything
that's happening their fault
because their parents are socks so there
is logic is [ __ ] and I think it's
normal and it's not normal so I'm also a
parent to be fighting with you and
yelling at you and you didn't do
anything wrong
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] they're not acting
can't wait for the GCS of the magazine
hope you guys enjoyed that episode if
you guys have any juicy little guts of
details and you guys want to submit it
well guess what you can cruise on over
to the description box below click on
the link submit the story and hopefully
we will pick it and talk about it for
more videos click right over here
[Music]